[Música]
nací en una familia emprendedora desde
que tenía 4 o 5 años de edad mi mamá y
mi tía empezaron a importar productos
plásticos para el hogar y distribuirlos
en costa rica dieciocho años después
tuve la oportunidad de trabajar en la
misma empresa y me di cuenta lo difícil
y retador que era ser dueño del negocio
sin embargo también me di cuenta que
gracias al esfuerzo de mis padres más de
50 familias se veían beneficiadas con
los salarios de nuestros trabajadores y
aún más de 10 mil familias obtenían
ingresos gracias a la fuerza de ventas
conformada en su mayoría por mujeres
sin embargo por mucho tiempo me dije a
mí misma aquí está la foto de mi mamá
disculpe sin embargo me dije a mí misma
que era más fácil ser asalariada en una
empresa que trabajar 24/7 para mantener
mi propia empresa
y de hecho si veía a mi alrededor todos
mis amigos también eran asalariados y
eran contados con los dedos de la mano
los que se han convertido en sus propios
jefes
y entonces me surgió la pregunta por qué
es tan difícil emprender porque nos
cuesta tanto a nosotros los jóvenes
pensar en ser nuestros nuestros propios
jefes bueno pues se me ocurrieron varias
razones primero vivimos en una zona en
una región que se caracteriza por ser
difícil a la hora de crear nuevos
negocios y si vemos en nuestra educación
también está enfocada en hacerlos
profesionales para que trabajemos para
alguien más sin embargo es una región
que se caracteriza por estar necesitada
de nuevas ideas y nuevos puestos de
trabajo para poder progresar
latinoamérica es una región rica en
cuanto a cultura y diversidad sin
embargo nos quedamos atrás cuando se
trata de crear nuevas empresas y cuando
se trata de innovación tal vez por miedo
por falta de dinero por falta de apoyo o
por falta de iniciativa sin embargo
tenemos que ser conscientes que para
poder erradicar la pobreza
tenemos que crear empleos empleos que
signifiquen trabajos y oportunidades no
sólo para los más preparados sino
también para los que todavía no han
tenido la oportunidad de prepararse sólo
de esa manera vamos a crear la riqueza
necesaria para poder hacer que nuestros
países salgan adelante
hace un tiempo viene una charla aquí y
nos comentaron que la misión de incae no
era educar gerentes la misión en caer o
educar líderes que se convirtieran en
agentes de cambio positivo en la región
hoy por hoy somos más de 620 millones de
latinoamericanos y si lo dividimos entre
el total de inka estos graduados hasta
el día de hoy podríamos decir que nos
toca a cada uno de nosotros ser
responsables del cambio para más de
200.000 personas la otra vez un amigo me
decía que eso es casi seis veces el
tamaño del estadio nacional de costa
rica esto es mucha gente sin embargo es
un reto que deberíamos estar dispuestos
a lograr nuestra misión como en caístas
es crear fuentes de empleo accesibles e
incluyentes que contribuyan a traer el
desarrollo de nuestros países y yo sé a
veces es difícil pensar en que en ser un
emprendedor y crear una nueva empresa
sin embargo si nos pensamos si nos
ponemos a pensar nosotros ya tenemos
esas herramientas lo que pasa es que a
veces nos auto saboteamos y pensamos que
ya todo está hecho que hay mucha
competencia
tenemos poco dinero y que se necesita
mucho para empezar o que simplemente no
tenemos tiempo sin embargo tenemos que
estar seguros de que nosotros también
tenemos los conocimientos y los medios y
los contactos necesarios para poder
emprender
imagínense que si de cada generación de
encaje por lo menos el 5 por ciento de
los estudiantes se decidiera a hacer sus
propios negocios al salir de incae
tendríamos casi 20 ideas nuevas al año
que significarían más oportunidades para
más personas a medida que están en la
que crecen arriesgue a monos pensemos en
que nos gustaría dedicar nuestro tiempo
en cuántas personas queremos ayudar o
cuántos problemas queremos solucionar y
empecemos a hacer esos proyectos que
tanto nos interesan o tal vez ya tenemos
esa idea clara eso ese plan súper
específico pero nos parece que está muy
arriesgado empecemos ya recordemos que
aquí estamos obteniendo todas las
herramientas y todos los conocimientos y
contactos necesarios para hacer nuestras
propias empresas y para generar más
oportunidades para más personas
recordemos que cada uno de nosotros
tenemos el poder de generar más
oportunidades y de hacer que más
personas nos sigan con una sola idea y
con las ganas de hacer aprovechemos que
estamos jóvenes que estamos jóvenes y
que tenemos
e inteligencia que tenemos los contactos
que tenemos un mercado gigante
como los latinoamerica y más allá de eso
aprovechamos que tenemos la energía y
las ganas de salir adelante que nos
caracterizan
tiempo después de haber trabajado con
mis papás me di cuenta que tener una
empresa propia no era tan feo como como
me lo imaginaba era difícil si es muy
difícil sin embargo después de haber
trabajado ahí me di cuenta que era una
meta que yo quería alcanzar y después de
salir de inka eso es lo que quiero hacer
quiero emprender mi propia empresa y es
por eso que estoy aquí hoy hoy quiero
que ustedes se vayan con la idea de que
ser emprendedor no es no necesariamente
es una posibilidad para ustedes sino que
debería ser una meta un objetivo que
ustedes deberían alcanzar y por eso los
invito a que salgamos hoy y venga ya
convertirnos en los empresarios más
grandes de nuestra generación y creemos
un futuro diferente en latinoamérica
convirtámonos en los líderes de américa
latina que ayuden a traer el progreso y
seamos en parte de ese grupo de personas
que cambien nuestros futuros para bien
porque es que si no lo hacemos nosotros
entonces quién lo hará
gracias
[Aplausos]